Sergey pavlovich Tom Aspen it's great
for the fight fans it's great for the
UFC it's great for the UFC brass it's
great for all the brands involved with
the UFC that they can put together a
world title fight between Sergey and Tom
Aspen on two weeks donus it's great it
sucks for the fighters but remember that
you're getting these guys at 80% you
know so they they're not going on full
camps I think Tommy gets it done like
you said last week if you watch the show
I think Tom Aspen's fight IQ is much
higher this is not going to be a quick
one it's going to be a a slow burn so I
think Tom asol takes his time uses his
footwork he knows the power of Sergey
early on he also the power of sergey's
hips early on and as that wears down Tom
as to start going to work in the third
fourth round I think he gets a TKO or
probably submission in the late third
fourth maybe fifth but I think third or
fourth Tom gets it done